Land und Brecht
[Musik]
so schönen guten Morgen die Runde ja
schönen guten Morgen guten Morgen guten
Morgen so eine dritte Stimme heute
Videopodcast wir wollen diesen mega
Trend ein bisschen Rechnung tragen unser
zweiter Video-Podcast und heute
besondere Ausgabe mit einem speziellen
Gast das erste Mal dass wir diese kleine
runde erweitern mit Reinhold Messner
schönen guten Morgen Reinhold guten
Morgen hat auch Reinhold ich freue mich
sehr 57 Ausgabe glaube ich ne 57 hauskam
unglaublich Wahnsinn also unter den
beiden Philosophen
da sitzt der Philosoph da die Legende da
der Yeti
[Musik]
genau
Reinhold ganz kurz bevor wir über dieses
und jenes sprechen und ich freue mich
sehr auf dieses Gespräch weil ich das
bewusst sehr gerne ganz offen halten
würde aber eine Frage habe ich dennoch
gleich zu Beginn die Wahlen in Italien
du kennst den ein oder anderen der
Beteiligten da jetzt wie schaust du auf
diese Wahl in Italien und wie viel
Sorgen macht ihr das
also so würde ich nicht sagen weil ich
ein alter habe warum ich das nicht mehr
richtig betrifft und 70 gewordener
Glückwunsch
aber natürlich die Kinder trifft es
Südtirol wird es auch treffen wir haben
einen Populisten ja mit großen
Fähigkeiten das ist ja sehr negativ
mit dem ich zusammengekracht bin also
damals bei den Kastelruther
spatzenauftrag also der ging in ein
Festzelt 10.000 Leute Kastelruther
Spatzen der Spatzenfest das berühmte
geben ihm das Mikrofon du darfst nie
einen Populisten ein Mikrofon geben
Gottes Willen ja und der macht eine
Wahlkampfrede und ich habe dann das
kritisiert öffentlich kritisiert hat er
mir einen ein Mail geschrieben und hat
sich erklärt warum er das macht und da
würde gern mit mir ein Gespräch führen
habe ich natürlich verweigert und ich
habe auch bei los Conny kennengelernt
noch in seinen ja brauchbaren Zeiten
immer EU-Parlament
muss ich jetzt daran denke dass eine
spätfaschistin aber mit ganz klaren
verzichtlichen Anwandlungen junge Frau
eine sehr aggressive Frau wie weit sie
populistin ist kann ich noch nicht sagen
weil ich keinen Wahlkampfauftritt
gesehen habe mit einem Populisten und
mit einem ja einem gewieften
Unternehmer der Italien ja nur
ausgenommen hat in seiner
Zeitvorstellung was immer er gemacht hat
er verurteilt wenn es wieder
zurückgekehrt war mehrmals
Ministerpräsident hat Italien in keiner
Weise weiter gebracht in seiner Zeit war
Italien wirklich am Rande des bankrots
wirklich am Abgrund zwei zwölf da habe
ich auch Sorge dass die EU dann Gelder
zurückhält die versprochen sind im
Rahmen von corona-krise und dann das
ganze explodiert jetzt muss man
natürlich schauen ob der Staatspräsident
Martha heller
Regierungsbildung überhaupt
Vorsicht da musst du ja der Melone den
Auftrag geben die Regierung zu bilden ob
es auch schaffen dass sie nicht zum von
Anfang an Streifen aber es gibt den
Trost das Italiens Regierungen nicht
lange hält das sagt mein Bruder auch der
sagt immer Markus mach dir keine Sorgen
in einem Jahr sind die eh wieder
Geschichte
ganz sicher nein zwei Jahren ist das
vorbei dann springen Parlamentarier in
eine andere Partei und dann ist das
ganze wieder anders es war höchste Zeit
dass die Cinque Stelle ja an den Rand
gedrängt wurden wo sie immer noch viele
Stimmen haben genau aber das war ein ja
eine komikerpartei da kommt sie auch her
und sie haben dann schon versucht das
seriös zu sein aber waren viele Leute
drinnen die kaum bis drei zählen können
also unsere Demokratie unsere Demokratie
in Italien ist eine ganz eigene
also es ist alles nicht so extrem es ist
alles ein bisschen vorher übermütiger
hält nicht lange aber richtige
Demokratie ist das keinem mehr mit zu
sagen nein das ist keine also seit den
Tagen von Berlusconi nicht mehr und auch
danach nicht gewesen in deinem Haus hat
ja innerhalb von einem halben Jahr
meiner unter ja Aufsicht Stand von der
Justiz eine Partei gegründet Vorzeit
Daniel und hat die Wahl gewonnen die
Datei gab es nicht ja draußen Null
erfunden als medienmodus das war die
erste
mediendiktatur weltweit also mit den
Medien hat er das ganze gewonnen da
waren Trump hat hat sich öfter darauf
berufen Trump hat öfter gesagt das ist
das was ich eigentlich im Kopf habe
genau das Ding Medienkontrolle der
Medien eigener Kanal eigene Plattformen
so wie es mein Freund Silvio in Italien
eine Partei für den eigenen Zuschnitt zu
des wobei man sagen muss das können auch
Demokraten machen macron ist auch ein
Beispiel oder auch eine Partei um eine
Person herum erfunden Sebastian Kurz
Sebastian Kurz im Prinzip also der der
alte Name wurde noch benutzt ja aber es
war natürlich auch eine Partei um einen
Politiker rum das scheint ja mehr und
mehr modisch aber Meloni das ist schon
eine eine unglaubliche Geschichte muss
ich überlegt dies ich glaube ihr seid im
Alter von 15 in der Politik ist jetzt
Mitte 40 ungefähr
angefangen mit 1% 1,5% und dann
sukzessive immer weiter gesteigert und
plötzlich bist du die erste weibliche
Regierungschefin die Italien jemals
hatte richtig aber am Beginn hat für die
Partei nicht an der Hand gehabt das
waren die Männer und dass sie allein die
Kraft gehabt hat diese fratelle in
Italien das ist ein männlich wie man
fratelli die Brüder Italien vor genau
und sie übernimmt diese Partei und
führte jetzt ist sie die wirkliche
Königin in dieser Partei und
gesundheitsregierungschef in Berne bin
ich sicher
sie wird auch stark genug sein denn die
Regierung zu führen also wirklich zu in
der Hand zu haben wie lange allerdings
das lasse ich da hingestellt sein weil
verändern wird sich nicht viel es wird
weiter das Länder ihren sein es wird
weiter im prozesswesen Nichts
weitergehen kann man sagen die Italiener
nehmen die Politik ein bisschen weniger
ernst als die Deutschen das ist richtig
ja
drin oder so eine Laune oder so ich weiß
es nicht es ist eine Frage ja außer die
Italiener nehmen die Politik nie so
ernst für die Deutsch weil sie auch
wissen dass die Politik am Ende sowieso
nicht viel zu sagen hat und dass sie
ständig wechselt ja
entscheidend und am Ende die Bürokraten
die Verwaltung dass der Punkt ich will
nur sozusagen dem Eindruck
entgegentreten dass die Italiener dann
also die italienische Bevölkerung nicht
seriös mit dem Thema umgeht die sind
glaube ich einfach verzweifelt die haben
das Gefühl es ist egal wen wir wählen es
geht immer das gleiche weil das ein
dysfunktionalen
emotionaler Staat besteht ja nicht nur
aus einer Regierung genau das
funktionaler Staat besteht eben aus
einer dysfunktionalen Bürokratie eine
dysfunktionalen Verwaltung
dysfunktionalen Gerichten ja also alle
Institutionen die letztlich Gewähr dafür
leisten dass ein staatgut funktioniert
wenn die nicht richtig funktionieren ist
doch völlig egal am Ende wer in der
Regierung ist die Dysfunktionalität
bleibt ja die ist ja eigentlich auf
einer Ebene auf der gar nicht gewesen
ist also so viel zu Italien freue mich
dass wir heute mal mit Reinhold Messner
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
persönlicher werden können Reinelt hat
dieser Tage finde ich interessant einen
Buch gemacht zum Thema Verzicht
und ich fand das deswegen interessant
weil wenn man sich das mal durchdenkt
dann versteht man das eigentlich deine
ganze Karriere das was du gemacht hast
das was dich erfolgreich gemacht hat das
baut eigentlich auf Verzicht auf und du
beschreibst diese irreszene wie viel
Gerüst Ausrüstung wie viel wie viel Zeug
ihr dabei hatte bei deiner ersten
Mount Everest-Expedition glaube ich was
nein man wird was wie viel hattet ihr
dabei neun Tonnen Ausrüstung neun Tonnen
ja für 18 Leute und du hast es später
gemacht mit das kleinste was ich gemacht
habe mit 60 Kilo
das ist Verzicht das heißt du bist mit
60 Kilo auf dem Flughafen quasi
angekommen und mehr ist gar nicht mehr
zugekommen mit 60 Kilo war ich in Raum
auf dem Flughafen und bin ich nach
Pakistan gefahren und habe diese 60 Kilo
ins Basislager gebracht im Basislager
hatte ich die Möglichkeit
fleischbrot was noch Milch zu kaufen von
dem Bergbauern die da oben Almwiesen
hatten also ich war oberhalb drei
Minuten gegen halbe Stunde runter und
habe das einfach bei den Einheimischen
gekauft aber sonst brauchte ich nichts
andere hatte ich alles dabei allerdings
diese Expedition dauerte viel weniger
lang als den angabert Expedition 70 also
70 wurde ich eingeladen zum nangabarbert
wir mussten eine Kleinigkeit sagen das
war für mich ein Jahresgehalt als Lehrer
aber ich hatte auch nicht mehr Geld und
wir haben alle dafür bezahlt und
Expeditionsleiter hat sich das Recht
vorbehalten allein über das Unternehmen
zu berichten also wir durften kein Wort
darüber schreiben aber wir waren froh
dass er mitgehen durften und
Expeditionsleiter ein Nichtbergsteiger
also das ganze so organisiert dass das
Zeug bis an den Fuß des Berges brachte
na gut organisiert dass er viel Mühe mit
Sponsoren die Geldern zu bleiben ich
hätte sowas nie selber finanzieren
können
weil das Hinterland viel zu klein war
Südtirol und dann habe ich angefangen
eigene Expeditionen zu machen 75 mit
einem Bruchteil dessen sobald Peter
haberler am hittenbig da hatten wir 200
Kilogramm da brauchen wir immer noch 10
Träger 10 Tage lang von der letzten
Stelle wo ein Jeep hinkommt bis ins
Basis sein und dann haben wir den Tag so
bestiegen mit den Alpen da im Stand der
alten Stil also die Frage war dann nicht
nur welche Route wir haben neue Route
geklettert eine schwierige Route also
der Weg war das Ziel und das Ziel begann
wichtig zu werden aber den verzichten
heute habe ich dann mit der Zeit
erfunden indem ich immer mehr verzichtet
habe ich brauche das nicht ich brauche
das nicht ich brauche das nicht und
durch das Abwerfen von Palast war ich
nicht nur schneller ich konnte mehr
Expeditionen machen als andere damit
einen Erfahrungsvorsprung holen und
Traditionen jetzt mit 60 Kilo auf den
nangabarbert haben natürlich viele Leute
auf die vortragsplätze geholt und meine
Bücher wurden erfolgreicher und damit
war das ein sehr interessantes Spiel es
war in erster Linie wirtschaftlich
gesehen ein Erfolg weil meine Kosten
gering waren geringe Kosten aber damit
einen größeren Erfolg weil ich ja dieses
elegante
verzichtsberg steigen auch besser
anschließend als nächstes
[Musik]
rudimentärer gemacht ja und damit
sozusagen wieder wieder aralischer also
da ist in einer Welt die immer mehr
technische Ausrüstung und Hilfsmittel
bereitgestellt hat immer bewusster auf
diese verzichtet und damit quasi dein
Bergsteigen als Uhr Naturerlebnis
darstellen können was es auch war und
nicht als technische Meisterleistung
immer da hochkommt was war bei dem
Verzicht dein Hauptantrieb war der
Hauptantrieb zu gewesen dass man das
alles nicht braucht also war das ein
sportlicher Ehrgeiz oder war der
Hauptantrieb zu sagen das ist quasi
natürlicher also spielt den ökologisches
bewunder der dritte Grund möglicherweise
du hattest gar nicht die Kohle um die
mehr Ausrüstung zu leisten also Anfang
angefangen hat das mit der tatsächliche
dass ich die Kohle nicht hatte dass ich
das Geld nicht hatte aber dann habe ich
in diese Form des Bergsteigens mir ging
es dann wirklich um die Art und Weise
habe ich den Sinn gesehen also eine
Bergbesteigung ist ja nicht sinnvoll
Apriori es ist wirklich nutzlos für die
Allgemeinheit für mich persönlich kann
es nützlich sein wenn ich einen
Bestseller liefere dann verdiene ich
auch Geld damit aber mit dem Vorsatz
gehe ich nie zum Berg ich gehe zum Berg
und sage ich möchte das oder jenes
erklettern aber da Verzicht hat mir den
Hauptsinn in das Unternehmen reingelegt
dann habe ich eingelegt das Sinn hieß
mit dem wenigsten Ausrüstungen
Materialien helfen da hin aufzukommen
heute passiert genau das Gegenteil jetzt
gehen im Frühling so im März 100 bis 150
scharpass zum Everest und bauten eine
Piste vom Basislager bis zum Gipfel und
dann kommen Kunden die in einem
Reisebüro eingekauft haben Basislager
Everest bis zum Gipfel und zurück und
kaufen das für angeblich gibt es jetzt
einzelne Persönlichkeiten die 6
Millionen Euro bieten für sicheres auf
den Everest kommen
also brauche ich zehn Schaper mit Gipfel
Garantie sonst gibt es gar nicht so eine
gipfelgarantie die besten Jumper können
das auch machen die haben so viel
Erfahrung die machen das da stehen dann
überall Lager so alle 500 Meter Höhe mit
Arzt mit Koch mit
kitchenbräude sind schon aufgestellt man
kann diese Reisen machen wie eine Reise
die ich buche nach Mallorca natürlich
ist das immer noch anstrengend aber die
haben es Sauerstoffgeräte die geben so
viel Sauerstoff her dass man steigt wie
auf 5.500 Meter inzwischen ist es Mode
geworden mit dem Hubschrauber von
Kathmandu einzufliegen sich daheim zu
akklimatisieren in einem
unterdruckzentrum
und dann fliegen sie ins Lager 2 bleiben
ein paar Tage fliegen wieder zurück ins
Basislager Lager 2 und dann gehen sie
zum Gipfel bekommen meine der ultimative
Verzicht war ja in deinem Fall er
Verzicht auf künstlichen Sauerstoff
ja dort wurde es dann ja klar dass das
eine andere Welt ist immer das hatte nie
jemand vorher gemacht nein wenn man
losgeht die hat mich gefragt wenn man
sowas macht und jeder Mediziner jeder
Bergsteiger jeder schärfer sagte was auf
das geht nicht du wirst da oben umkommen
und wenn du das alleine machst kommst du
erst recht um wie verabschiedet man sich
zu Hause und wie bereitet man sich auf
die Möglichkeit zu sterben vor also bei
mir war das so dass ich diese Touren für
mich behalten habe und natürlich daheim
gesagt hat ich war zumindest aber die
Art und Weise hätte bei mir daheim
niemand hinterfragen können natürlich
andere Darsteller ja also als ich 78 mit
Peter herberle auf ein einfaches Steg im
Vorfeld hat die Medizin eindeutig
gewarnt und gesagt das geht nicht das
Gehirn spielte an und zueinander das
Gehirn nein das
schon sehr krank also
das ist ein Gehirn in dem also das sind
viele Leute dran
wenn du da oben bist also
sauerstoffpatiendruck es geht nicht es
ist oben das Verhältnis Stickstoff
Sauerstoff und Edelgase das gleiche wie
herum nur ist in einem Kubikmeter Luft
viel weniger von diesen Elementen
hineingepresst vor allem vom Sauerstoff
genau und wenn ich zu wenig Sauerstoff
kriege dann habe ich im großen Ganzen
keine Kraft mehr obwohl ich nicht mehr
Energie brauche in meinem Blut wie auf
normaler Höhe aber wenn kein Sauerstoff
zum Blut kommt dann brennt das passiert
ja nichts mehr jetzt habe ich meine
frage weil ich habe von Vortrag mal von
dir gehört und dann hast du erzählt du
bist erst auf den Everest gestiegen ja
und dann bist du bist du auf allen
Vieren gegangen und ich glaube die
letzten 50 Meter quasi gerockt oder so
weil man da auch jetzt stelle ich mir
eine Frage wenn man so wenig Sauerstoff
noch hat und wenn man quasi so schwach
ist jeder kennt ja so ein bisschen den
Zustand Sauerstoffmangel oder so zu
haben wieso bleibt denn ausgerechnet bei
dir noch der Wille übrig also der müsste
doch eigentlich bei der durch den
Sauerstoffmangel zerstört sein wieso ist
der Wille stärker ja als die ganze
restliche Schwäche des Körpers also
warum geht man nicht irgendwann einfach
auf und sagt okay ich ergebe mich jetzt
du hast gewonnen ja manchmal der Zustand
in dem man sich da befindet ist ja kein
Normalzustand mehr man ist ja alles nur
noch schwach und Elend und furchtbar ein
richtig völlig richtig erkannter Wille
lässt nach der Welle wird nur mehr ein
Teil dessen was er normalerweise ist
auch die Entscheidungsfreude alles ich
habe mich
öfters so selber nicht beobachtet aber
ich habe mich beobachtet wie langsam das
alles geht wie langsam ich denke wie
langsam der Wille wieder ausreicht um
einen Schritt zu tun ganz oben
und wenn ich jetzt über Jahre hinweg ein
Projekt im Voraus Vollzug mit mir
herumgetragen habe in meinem Kopf dann
kann ich eben mehr Motivation
freischalten mehr im wilden freischalten
wenn es dann eng wird wenn ich nur so
erhobe ein bisschen ja jetzt habe ich
Lust auf ein Everest zu steigen getan
hätte dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich nicht
weit gekommen die die darauffolg in
Grenzbereichen wo man kaum noch
weiterkommt hängt in erster Linie davon
ab wie viel Sinn ich meine Grund gegeben
habe bei der aber der Sinn Reinhold der
Sinn ne ich meine erste
Expedition großexition langhaarpert dein
Bruder Günther stirbt
du bist dabei fast gestorben du hast mir
mal die Geschichte erzählt wie du selber
irgendwie mehr oder weniger auf allen
Vieren darunter gekrochen bist und dann
von irgendwelchen Menschen wer von
Mauern gefunden worden ist du hattest
ein ein Nahtoderlebnis saß dich
sozusagen selber in diesem Schutt in
dieser Geröll da liegen und die finden
dich schleppst dich irgendwie dahin und
die
holen Dich nicht rein ins Haus weil sie
davon ausgehen dass du sowieso stirbst
ja aber das habe ich überlebt und ich
trug dann natürlich dieses gerade dieses
Nahtoderlebnis dass ich dort erstmals
hatte und in dieser Intensität nie mehr
wieder das drücke ich in mir und das ist
das stärkste das du erleben kannst
beschreibt das mal ja was was macht eine
Nahtoderfahrung eine so intensive wie du
sie gehabt hast was macht die mit einem
in erster Linie wird klar dass wir
sterblich sind
und dann wird klar dass das überhaupt
nicht schlimm ist du hast das nicht als
schlimm empfunden das heißt du hattest
in dem Moment wo du da auf allen Vieren
im Schneesturm darunter ist keine
Todesangst es war was es war die
Situation ist die wir kommen am Gipfel
mein Bruder wird töten krank wir gehen
runter ein Stückchen weiter und
biberieren also wir mächtigen ohne
Schlafsack ohne Zelt ohne alles
eigentlich auch kein kochen
und diese Nacht hätte tödlich sein
können für uns beide wie viel welche
Temperatur zwischen 30 und 40 Grad Minus
und da bist Du absolut unterkühlt und
das ganze Körper schlottern um sich so
einigermaßen am Leben zu halten und wir
waren in weil der schlottern das Zittern
Wärme erzeugt sozusagen
kannst du nichts dagegen tun und dann
waren wir auch noch in der prekären
Situation nicht mehr runterzukommen vom
Berg weil die Wand über dem
hochgestiegen waren die waren nicht
machbar im Abstieg ohne Seilgarten beide
Kennzeichen diese die haben ja Flanke
runter die kanntet ihr von einer
Postkarte nein
eine Postkarte ach okay ja habe ich
übrigens Christoph ransmeier im
Schriftsteller geschenkt okay vielleicht
macht er meine Roman drüber okay also
die
dieses Foto hatte ich noch anschließend
das Warten die verbraucht aber man kann
es noch sehen und das war jetzt ein
langer Abstieg ne also ihr seid
sozusagen
entschieden habe wo wir runtergehen
hatte ich dieses NATO unterleibnis ich
fiel ihm in einer Art Verzweiflung
sah mich von oben so von fünf sechs
Meter Höhe wie ich den Berg
herunterrolle es war nicht steil ich
konnte nicht abstürzen ich bin nur so
der Länge nach runtergerollt ein Stück
und sah mich von außen und dann bin ich
mit einem Schrei aufgestanden sehr
schnell und habe dann
kaltblütig entschieden was wir tun und
bis zum Ende kaltblütig das durchgezogen
angesichts des Todes und wir wissen ja
Apriori theoretisch könnten wir auch
rumkommen Nanga Baba truppelwand die
umkommen Möglichkeit war nicht Null wird
das Leben absurd wird klar also was
gestern war oder morgen ist ist völlig
unwichtig
es geht nur mehr ums hier und jetzt um
das Leben zu retten um das ist doch
selbst Erhaltungstrieb der dich zwingt
sozusagen aber wenn du sagst dass dir
das die Angst vor dem Tod genommen hat
nachhaltig nein oder ist die Angst vor
dem Tod zurück genau also das die Angst
vor dem Sterben krank zu werden zu
sterben die ist da also das hat mit mir
Haltern zu tun das ist die Angst ist ja
es gibt ja eine Art die eine Angst ist
die Angst vor dem Sichtum ja und oder
Demenz zu werden und so weiter ist ja
was anderes als die Angst vor dem nicht
mehr da sein diese Angst vor dem nicht
mehr da sein hast du die nein der hat
mich ziemlich abgestreift und schon
damals seit damals mehr damals war ein
Gefühl beschreibt das mal ist das ist
das ist das ein warmes Gefühl ist das
ein gutes Gefühl ist dass das Gefühl der
Erlösung es ist vorbei was ist das für
uns das ist ein gefühlter Lösung weniger
ein Gefühl dass es vorbei ist
alles andere ist besser als das was da
gerade ist nein nein das ist eigentlich
die Erlösung der Freiraum zu
Sterben zu verschwinden und dieses
Gefühl wenn man wenn man sozusagen da
oben über sich selber schwebt
sehnt man sich nach diesem Gefühl immer
wieder zurück also für mich sei damals
ist
der Tod
das herausgehen aus einer aus einer Welt
die auch im Raum spürbar ist in eine
Zeitlosigkeit
absolute Zeitlosigkeit und das gibt dir
gewisses Geborgenheitsgefühl also quasi
aus dem Gedanken dass man aus aus Staub
ist und zum Staub zurückkehrt dass man
wieder eins wird mit dem Kosmos dass man
wieder aufgeht so gesund Gefühl von
Verschmelzungen unter konkrete
haptische Kosmos nicht nicht irgendeinen
Fantasiegebilde ist schon klar
irgendwo oben auf dem Berg wenn ich
weiter schauen kann meine Wüste hinein
wo niemand anderer ist oder mein Partner
vielleicht mein Kletterpartner neben mir
ist in die
absolute Entschleunigung in die
Zeitlosigkeit in die Unendlichkeit aus
den Raum angeht
das schaue ich genau hinein das ist für
mich das was
nach einer
nahtoderlebnisgeschichte bleibt okay
interessanterweise Reinhold wir haben da
uns im Podcast auch schon drüber
unterhalten ich hatte Gott sei Dank
keine Nahtoderfahrung aber ich hatte
Angst wenn ich nicht sagen ja gut du
willst sie nicht missen ja das ist ein
hochinteressant aber ich möchte dich in
eine Situation bringen wo ich sie habe
sagen wir drücken wir es mal so aus
diese sich auf eine lustvolle Art und
Weise klein und krümelig zu fühlen ja
vor der unendlichen Natur ist auch für
mich das Gefühl dass mir am meisten die
Angst vor dem Tod nimmt und zwar ohne
dass ich jetzt solche Dinge erlebt habe
wie du ja aber wenn ich ich habe das
schon als Beispiel nach dem Preis Canyon
diesen unendlichen Sternenhimmel der wie
eine Glocke ein umhüllt und einschließt
fühle ich mich geborgen im Kosmos
Landschaften wo ich ja häufiger war ja
dieses diese absolute Leere und dieses
Nichts das einem quasi empfängt und man
denkt man ist ein Teil davon und man
geht wieder dahin zurück und das ist
nichts schlimmes also diese Gedanken
kenne ich auch ohne die Nahtoderfahrung
sind die dir erst nach der
Nahtoderfahrung so gekommen also in
jungen Jahren habe ich das natürlich
nicht aufgeschrieben auch nicht
aufgezeichnet diese Nahtoderfahrung die
ich vorher erzählt habe habe ich
unmittelbar danach aufgeschrieben in
einem Buch und es gab den Ausdruck nicht
es gab noch keine Erfahrung über die
Philosophen die dann später über das
Sterben geschrieben haben was passiert
da sondern das war einfach eine
Erfahrung die mir am stärksten in
Erinnerung geblieben ist und ich habe
sie in der roten Rakete aufgeschrieben
und habe dann später sie immer wieder
natürlich
erinnert wenn ich das nachgelesen habe
sonst werden wir das auch verloren
gegangen aber ich habe ein ganzes Buch
dazu gemacht von Nahtoderfahrungen die
andere erzählen und alles sagen das
gleiche das ist das Schlimmste und das
großartigste was man erleben kann du
bist ja der der quasi der Inbegriff
eines praktischen Philosophen es gibt
zwar eine Disziplin die nennt sich
praktische Philosophie die meine ich
nicht sondern von dir stammen ja sehr
sehr viele Sätze in die Richtung gehen
dass man das Leben oder sich selbst am
ersten in Grenzsituationen überhaupt
begreift also indem man das Naturwesen
dass man ist frei von allem kulturellen
und gedanklichen Ballast in sich erspürt
und auch nicht mehr denkt nehmt
eigentlich kann man sozusagen nur wissen
wer man ist oder was man ist wenn man
nicht mehr denkt das ist natürlich
erstmal das Gegenteil nicht der
fernöstlichen aber das Gegenteil der
westlichen Philosophie
interessierst du dich für Philosophie
siehst du deine Brücke glaubst du dass
Leute durch Nachdenken so ähnlichen
Schlüssen kommen können wie du durch
Erlebnisse also das glaube ich nicht ich
glaube schon dass man mit nachdenken
oder Philosophie ist in erster Linie
Philosophie Geschichte wenn jemand jetzt
wirklich die Philosophen studiert und
liest und versucht sie auch zu verstehen
dann kann er oder kann sie im Laufe der
Zeit natürlich einiges erkennen was ich
nur naiv erkenne also bei mir findet das
naiv statt
es ist wirklich so dass wir ihn aber
welches naiv ja kein negatives Wort
sondern naiv im Sinne rein und
unmittelbar ja
also bei mir ist es so dass ich
die Wildnis als eine Art Plattform finde
wenn auch in vielen Dimensionen um zu
verstehen wie ich wirklich dicke
deswegen auch die Nachrichten
Verhaltensmuster wenn wir zu zweit oder
zu viert in eine große
Abenteuergeschichte hineingehen wohl
wissen dass wir umkommen könnten
reagieren wir nach inneren Gesetzen aber
nicht mehr nach irgendeiner
oder nach einer irgendeiner Ethik
sondern wir reagieren nach inneren
Gesetzen wir geben wenn etwas passiert
im Notfall im äußersten Notfall
den schweigend ohne zu nicken ohne Hand
aufzuhalten dem stärksten
psychophysikstärksten das ledership
was bringt das hervor Reinhold wenn du
sagst da geht es jetzt nicht mehr um
Moral bringt das das Beste im Menschen
hervor oder bringt es sozusagen das
schlechteste Menschen davor also wenn es
jetzt es gibt kein Bestes und schlechtes
mehr das gibt's nicht mehr das ist eine
moralische Kategorie aber wenn es jetzt
um du kannst aber von der zutiefst
moralischen Entscheidung plötzlich
stehen zum Beispiel vor der Frage lässt
du jetzt jemanden zurück um deine eigene
Haut zu retten oder gehst du mit drauf
also ich habe ja das alles erlebt man
hat mir 50 Jahre lang vorgeworfen ich
hatte den Bruder dein Bruder genau
du hattest auch bei der Expedition
danach sind zwei deiner Kameraden
gestorben das heißt gratis die ersten
richtig großen Expeditionen von dir also
Pflastern Leichen den Weg richtig
richtig gerade die mannschaftsposition
okay wo ich das erzähle ja zwei zwei
Leute gestorben
plus weiter das ist nichts mehr es ist
wie sind die gestorben wie ist das
passiert also wir waren zu zweit voraus
haben ein Zelt aufgestellt auf 7273
von dort sind wir am nächsten Tag
losgegangen das ist im Grunde Schneehang
also ein harter Schnee war gut zu gehen
und nach einer Stunde eineinhalb Stunden
sagt mein Partner er fühlt sich nicht
stark genug um den Gipfel den man noch
nicht sah weit weg zu erreichen
gegenüber zurück es war keine
Spaltengefahr es war überhaupt nichts da
und der ist zurückgegangen ist Zelt
musste ich annehmen aber eine Zeit lang
voraus noch gesehen dass er zurückgeht
aber dann sind so buckelwohl nein nicht
mehr zurück sein und ich bin auf dem
Gipfel gegangen und es kam gerade in
diesem Moment natürlich nicht in dieser
Minute ein sehr starker Strom von Süden
mit Nebeln ich habe dann schnell Kirch
gemacht und bin abgestiegen und steckte
nach vielleicht eineinhalb Stunden in
einem Schneesturm
aber auch mit weiterer Nebel
weiße Fläche
Schnee dann durch die Winde durch wenn
du siehst nichts mehr du siehst nichts
mehr
Orientierung fährst du um weil du gar
nicht weißt dass du dann doch getan bist
und ich bin dann im Kreis gegangen aber
das habe ich erst später am Abend
gemerkt da wurde schon langsam Nacht ich
war schon bereitet wenn ich das nicht
zeitig finde bin ich tot und dann habe
ich im letzten Moment
gemerkt ich gehe im Kreis das tut man
dann und zwar relativ kleinen Kreisen
man geht mal gar keine große Kreise aber
die Fläche war Fläche sonst ist das
nicht möglich sonst hast du an Hang da
ist unten und da ist oben sondern in der
Fläche gehst du im Kreis und ich wusste
ich habe das Zelt an der Kante an der
Kippe zwischen dieser Fläche Hochplateau
unter Steilwand nach Süden aufgestellt
und dann habe ich rational endlich
rational gedacht und gesagt ich muss
gegen den Sturm gehen weil ich habe
gemerkt der Sturm kommt von Süden also
kann das Zelt wenn ich auf der Fläche
bin nur im Süden sein und dann bin ich
gegen den Sturm gegangen und habe dann
gefunden ich mein Sohn
so ein schwarzer Punkt ja also Punkt die
Ideen dann zu finden und da waren da war
nicht der Franz Jäger der umgekommen ist
später denn ich erwartet habe ich gehe
zum Zelt hin und schreibe Franz nicht
und dann kommt ein anderer heraus zwei
andere
heißen Fankhauser und Schlick sind am
gleichen Tag von unten aufgekommen um am
nächsten Tag eventuell auch zum Tippen
zu gehen und die waren da und den habe
ich erzählt ich habe diesen Franz Jäger
draußen auch noch rufen hören
da war ich hundertprozentig sicher der
ist irgendwo aber zuerst habe ich immer
das Zelt gesucht weil sonst hätte ich
ihm auch nicht helfen können ich habe
sogar angenommen der ruft aus dem Zelt
weil er verstanden hat ich bin in einer
prekären Situation in weiter ab und der
loggt mich zum Zelt aber lieber waren
andere die sind dann rausgegangen und
haben gesagt sie hören ihn auch sie
holen ihn gleich nach zehn Minuten haben
Sie die Orientierung verloren und sind
im Kreis gegangen und sind die ganze
Nacht draußen geblieben und einer ist
dann zurück geworden der hat es nicht
mehr ausgehalten die Kälte
die Angst unter anderem ist
zurückgekommen zum Zelt am nächsten Tag
allein und der Franz Jäger war
verschwunden ist bis heute verschwunden
das heißt was heißt verrückt geworden
der hat einfach durchgedreht
das ist nämlich das was du von gerade
beschrieben hast Richard zu sagen da ist
diese große Wüste da ist dieses
Universum über dir dieses Nahtoderlebnis
diese dieser Idee du wirst sozusagen
eins mit dem ganzen bin kein besonders
spiritueller Mensch aber den Gedanken
kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen ich
sage ganz offen
sowohl am am Südpol als auch einen
bestimmten Situationen in Grönland aus
auch am Nordpol mir macht das Angst und
für mich war das immer sozusagen der der
innere Kampf gegen die eigene Angst sie
mich solchen Situationen auszusetzen und
deswegen frage ich auch nach genau
dieser Situation was macht das mit dir
was bringt das in die hervor das ist der
entscheidende Punkt also ich habe Angst
wenn ich mir vorstelle ich lege dort in
einer Kiste
lebendig ist noch schlimmer deswegen
habe ich mir einen Grabmal gebaut wo das
nicht der Fall sein wird das so eine so
ein Schoten sein
du willst dürfen jetzt seit zwei Jahren
oder drei Jahren
auf der Gemeinde melden und sagen wir
wollen Feuer bestattet werden oder am
Friedhof begraben werden was die Leute
in Südtirol großteils wollen und ich
habe mir diesen Jordan gebaut weil ich
auch als Toter
sein
hast du mit der italienischen Bürokratie
mit der wir angefangen haben gekämpft
bis sie die erlaubt haben deine eigene
begräbnisstrate oft ein Grundstück zu
setzen na das kam von heute auf morgen
in den Medien dass man das darf ich bin
zur Gemeinde gegangen und dann hat dann
musst du auf die Gemeinde melden man
muss es aber die wussten nicht was ein
schorten ist nein nein
hast
den habe ich gebaut oder bauen lassen
natürlich weil er einfach dort gut
hinterlegst du dann wie eingeäschert
oder wie Englisch ich habe immer gedacht
Reinhold Messner wird anders sterben wir
haben darüber gesprochen ich habe
gedacht du gehst auf dem Berg und dann
sitzt du da so lange bis vorbei ist und
dann kommen die Adler und die Geier und
du wirst so Stein und er ist nein aber
das ist wiederum für mich so schönste
Vorstellung ja ich habe ja
ganz tiefe spirituelle Zuneigung zu
Greifvögeln und für mich ist das was die
passend machen ja dass die ihre Leichen
ja auf Türme liegen und die dann von den
Geiern fressen lassen ja damit du schon
mal Vorstellung für dich hier ist die
schöne Vorstellung weil quasi mit den
Geiern deine Seele genau
was mir also im Leben nicht gegeben ist
fliegen zu können würde dann quasi mit
etwas von mir ja der Tode realisiert
also es gibt viele Leute finden das
irgendwie gruselig und eklige
Vorstellung ich finde das schon richtig
schöne Fall sicher sichergestellt dass
du nicht allein in der Kiste lebst in
Südtirol ich meine ja es gibt ein paar
wieder angesiedelte aber auch da genug
kommen würden genug kommen würden ja
würden Dich am Ende würden ja deine
Knochen dann loslassen
ich war dabei einmal
in Tibet ist die himmelsbestattung das
schönste dass ich himmelsbestattung
der Beerdigung Beerdigungsinstitute
Bestattungen
beschreibt das und ich habe das gesehen
in dem wird an der Grenze Nepal die wird
zufällig und bin da hingegangen oder
Kultplatz ist man das passiert da ist
ein Mönch der den Toten der zehn Tage
schon tot ist aufschlitzt mit 100
messerschnitten den ganzen Rücken die
Arme die sogar die Finger also wir quasi
präpariert für die Vögel ja und während
das passiert ich komme hoch freigesetzt
wird ne es waren dort etwa 100 geil aber
riesige Geier
und die kommen von den Bergen herunter
also aus den nahen Bergen fliegen der
herab im ersten morgenlich schneegeier
und Frau setzen dann auf und da war ein
zweiter Mann der hat diese Geier in
Schach gehalten während der Mönch 2
Stunden lang seine Zeremonie gemacht hat
und dann hat der Mönch den Leichen am
freigegeben dann kamen diese Geier über
diesen Leichnam und es blieb nach zwei
drei Minuten nur das Knochengerüst ein
weißes Knochengerüst dann hat er Mensch
die Knochen zerstampft Stein gegen Stein
zu breit der Schädel wurde auf die Seite
gelegt alles
Zeremonie und dann hat er die Geier
vorgelassen dann haben die die Knochen
gefressen und am Ende wird unter Schädel
da stampft die Gehirnmasse vermischt ein
drittes Mal durften die Geier da sich
gütlich tun
und ich durfte das sogar fotografieren
und wie kannst du das ich fand es es war
schwer erträglich vom Geruch aber
sammeln die Einheimischen immer gefragt
darf ich in die Nähe gehen und am Ende
war waren alles Steine eine Steine da
die waren sauber wie gewohnt und die
einzelnen Geier sind aufgestiegen in den
Himmel bis sie als schwarze Punkte sich
verloren also das war das schönste Bild
und am Ende war kein Geier mehr da
absolute Stille hohe und nur noch der
saubere windjekte über die Steine und
jetzt natürlich der Code von diesen
Geiern fällt herunter unten wächst eine
Pflanze die Pflanze frisst ein Tier und
der Mensch ist das Fleisch das ist
natürlich nicht die Wiedergeburt aber es
ist auch der Kreislauf der angedeutet
werden und ich bin sicher dass die
Einheimischen als sie diese Feuer beim
Feuerbestattung plus
himmelsbestattung erfunden haben oder
keine andere Möglichkeit hatten im
Winter ist verboten gefroren in die
Flüsse kann man die Toten nicht werfen
Feuer kann man nur machen wenn man Holz
hat das gibt es in Diebe zum Teil nicht
genau also kamen sie auf diese Methode
und haben sie auch von einer anderen
Kultur übernommen das weiß ich nicht
das Gespräch mit diesen Leuten da nicht
möglich im Sinne von geistig
Auseinandersetzung
ich will euch da jetzt ungern rausreißen
aus diesen schönen Überlegungen ja wie
irgendwann sogar Kacke werde
so würde ich das jetzt nicht sagen also
ich ich kann dem was abgewinnen
tatsächlich weil ich so klaustrophobisch
bin und die Vorstellungen so der Kiste
zu liegen ist eine die mir absolut nicht
behagt
zurück ins Hier und Jetzt wir sind ja so
eine Gesellschaft die im Moment
wahnsinnig Angst hat sind ängstlich
geworden das Wort verzichtlöst bei uns
Dinge aus die Vorstellung nicht mehr mit
200 Sachen über die Autobahn zu ballern
löst bei uns schon schon schlimmste
Gefühle aus hat man manchmal den
Eindruck wenn ich dir so zuhöre würde
ich sagen erstens Verzicht kann etwas
sinnstiftendes sein erster Gedanke
und zweiter Gedanke
ich lerne gerade es dauert bis wir
sterben wir halten vielmehr aus als wir
so denken wir können auch viel mehr als
wir so denken also das wichtigste beim
Verzicht ist die Freiwilligkeit wenn ich
dem Verzicht aufgezwungen Kriege von der
Regierung oder vielleicht auch von
meiner Armut dann ist es etwas sehr
schwer zu akzeptieren aber wenn dann ist
Verzicht nämlich Mangel genau und ich
habe das auch so erlebt der wichtigste
Antrieb sozusagen daraus zu kommen
keinen Mangel zu haben war im Grunde das
was bei mir auch an den ziemlich ist das
Drüsen co2-abdruck ausgelöst hat ich
wollte daraus
und die der freiwillige Verzicht als
positiver Wert ist erstens
gebaut mit Lebensfreude
gepaart mit gelingendem Leben im Hier
und Jetzt
und nicht mit irgendwelchen negativen
Empfindungen du würdest zu dir sagen mit
der positiven Empfindung wie viel macht
man über sich selbst hat ist der beweist
der eigenen Willensfreiheit ich kann das
ich schaffe das ich komme dadurch das
ist das ist das Positive also du meinst
wir müssen Verzicht jetzt der ja aus
ökologischen Gründen mehr und mehr
notwendig werden
Challenge annehmen und sagen wir
beweisen daran wie souverän wir sind ja
wie stark wir sind so unter dieser
Perspektive wird Verzicht bei uns ja
nicht diskutiert das wird bei uns nur
als wegnehmen als Mangel und so weiter
diskutiert aber nicht dass man sich auch
daran beweisen kann naja es gibt ja da
verschiedene Ebene es gibt ja es gibt ja
sozusagen der Verzicht also es wird
einem was genommen das ist schmerzhaft
ja es ist umgekehrt viel angenehmer wenn
du es schaffst dich aus dem Mangel
rauszuarbeiten in eine Situation des
Wohlstands ist ja was völlig anderes als
aus einer Situation des Wohlstands
plötzlich in einen Mangel reinzufallen
und wir lernen die alle gerade
schmerzhaft
nicht so so Wörter wie Mangel die
tauchten ja in in unserer Welt waren die
abgeschafft es war ja ständig alles
alles verfügbar und was wir gerade
erleben ist sozusagen wenn wir schon mal
drüber gesprochen der Gegenentwurf zu
Amazon Prime eben nicht mehr alles
sofort und jetzt hast du eigentlich
schon mal was bei Amazon bestellt nein
also ich bestelle ich gehe nicht
einkaufen das macht zum Glück jemand für
mich meine Frau ich gehe nicht bei
irgendwo auf diesen Plattformen ich kann
das gar nicht
Einkaufen ich bin kein Konsum Mensch das
macht mir keine Freude ich bin jemand
der Ideen hat und diese Ideen zu
Projekten macht und diese Projekte dann
umsetzt und das ist meine Lebensfreude
ich kann dann wenn das Projekt fertig
ist es abgeht das ist aber das ist aber
etwas was nicht immer so war ne ich wenn
ich an dich denke Reinhold habe ich
immer ein ganz berühmtes Foto vor Augen
du in deinem Tal um Single von den
netten Leuten da aus dem Dorf Bergbauern
und so weiter und du mittendrin mit
einem Porsche
also es war dir mal wichtig
ja genau zweimal hatte
auch natürlich ein Hintergrund aber es
nicht wichtig ich habe ihn dann verkauft
für eine Expedition genau
mal zurück zu dem Punkt also wir haben
ja gerade so schlimme Wörter gelernt
gasmangel Lage ja
gellage kannte ich vorher gar nicht aber
jetzt ist sogar mangeladen Zeit langsam
ja man ertappt sich man macht den
Heizkörper mal so ein bisschen auf seine
Haare nee komm lass Mama lass noch mal
zu einer Woche halt die nur durch beim
Duschen morgen sagt man das Gefühl
gleich kommt einer von der Regierung
sagt oder frontieren 2 Minuten raus war
schon 30 Sekunden über der Zeit du bist
einigermaßen sauber so muss es gehen da
kommt dann berühmter Ministerpräsident
Winfried Kretschmann sagt du pass mal
auf Waschlappen geht auch mal so ich
fand das herrlich erfrischend das immer
so entspannt in die Republik reinruft
nimmt man Waschlappen dann seid ihr alle
sauber aber deine Botschaft Reinhold ist
doch eigentlich wir können wachsen an
dieser Geschichte und wir müssen nicht
so ängstlich sein und wir halten viel
mehr aus als wir können ich habe dieser
Tage dieses Buch von rudka brech man
brichmann du sprichst ihn immer so schön
aus gelesen von Natur aus gut ist ein
großartiges Buch war genau das
beschreibt deswegen habe ich vorhin
gefragt was holt sozusagen die
Extremsituation aus einem Menschen
heraus
das Gute oder das Schlechte und er weist
an vielen Beispielen nach das ist das
Gute ist dass es rausholt und er
beschreibt zum Beispiel 9/11 und sagt
das heute noch Leute davon erzählen dass
da nicht die große Panik war im Sinne
von jeder sich selbst der Nächste
sondern man hat sich den Vortritt
gelassen das hat nicht geh du zuerst ist
wichtig dass du gerettet wirst also
Menschen waren bereits sozusagen sich
selber zu Opfern nicht nur für Leute die
sie kannten sondern für wildfremde
Menschen das gleiche beschreibt er
anhand von von
Archiven
Angriff der deutschen auf London ja der
der der der Luft der Luft so der
Luftangriff wo er sagt die die Engländer
haben das mit einer erstaunlichen
Lässigkeit weggesteckt natürlich gab es
viel Wut und viel Hass aber am Ende ist
England als Nation daran gewachsen und
da gibt es so ein lakonischen Eintrag
von einem Historiker der der schreibt am
Ende hat das die Engländer als Nation
auf vielen Ebenen stärker gemacht Punkt
hitler war enttäuscht Punkt ja und der
beschreibt wie wie die Geschäfte
weitergingen wie Leute dann als ihnen
die Geschäfte kaputt gebombt wurden
draufgeschrieben haben heute besonders
weit geöffnet ja also mit Humor das
ganze aufgearbeitet haben und ähnliches
haben die Deutschen ja auch erlebt ich
meine in Dresden sind in einer Nacht
fast so viele Kinder Männer und Frauen
gestorben wie während der ganzen Zeit
der Angriffe auf London das muss man
sich mal vorstellen und trotzdem ist ein
kleiner Punkt als der Krieg bereits
genau und trotzdem ist dieses Land mit
einer unglaublichen Stärke daraus
hervorgekommen und ist und ist zudem
geworden was es eigentlich heute ist und
deswegen frage ich mich frage ist jetzt
auf dieser Situation dieser Winter also
nicht nur Deutschland sondern die
westlichen Wahrheiten stärker machen
oder nicht was glaubst du wenn die
Politiker in der Lage sind
das richtig zu erzählen was passiert
glaubwürdig und richtig zu erzählen dann
wird es positiv sein wobei ich das Wort
nicht gern benutze positiv oder negativ
weil vielleicht haben Problem damit mit
auch mit gut und schlecht ist ja wenn du
es für die Menschheit auf ewig anlegst
gibt es kein Gut und Schlecht mehr
erklär warum weil wir nicht wissen wie
diese Menschheit angelegt ist oder
wieder Kosmos angelegt ist auf was sind
wir angelegt also das was jenseits
meines Lebens ist ist jenseits was
jenseits meiner Erkenntnismöglichkeit
ist wo auch die Philosophen dann nur
mehr die Fragezeichen stellen also
Richard das der Meinung Bescheid aber
jenseitig das ist jenseits meiner du
bist quasi antimetaphysiker nein ich bin
impossibilist ja ich hatte einen
glücklichen aber nichts für gewiss auch
nicht die Anlage also ich kann sagen du
hättest auch kein Substanzielles Urteil
über den Menschen Fällen wollen du wirst
nicht sagen der Mensch ist von Natur aus
gut und du wirst eigentlich sagen er ist
von Natur aus schlecht ja sondern du
würdest sagen der Mensch von Natur aus
ist dazu beidem fähig Punkt der
Unterschied zwischen Temperatur die
absichtslos ist genau will gar nichts
die wertet nicht ist noch wieder
abschichten aber wir wissen nicht dass
diese Absichten ins leer eingesteckt
sind
ins Lehre gesteckt weil am Ende der Tod
weil wir keine so große Übersicht haben
genau weil wir nicht wissen ob unsere
Absichten die richtige Absichten
wir ein bisschen
nicht wie auf wie lange die Menschheit
angelegt ist oder auch nicht also im
Moment ist es so dass wir die Menschheit
in eine Situation führen dass sie
vielleicht nicht mehr allzu lange ja das
sind die schwer danach aus der 8000
Jahren ist das nicht wie mit dem eigenen
Tod ist es nicht gut dass man das nicht
weiß ist gut das muss nicht ich wäre
eine Katastrophe wenn man das wüsste
Katastrophe wenn wir ewig leben würden
wir würden uns nicht ertragen glaubst du
also glaube ich auch also ich glaube ich
glaube dass ihre parable ist der
Überdruss
ewig leben würden wir würden so
unglaublich überdrüssig werden ich
glaube auf die Nerven gehen jetzt wird
uns umbringen wenn wir überleben können
ja ich glaube tatsächlich also zum Thema
angelegt ist wir sind von Natur aus
nicht auf Unsterblichkeit angelegt und
das ist sehr sehr tief kommt aber seid
mal ehrlich ich meine Reinhold gerade 78
geworden wie alt bist du 57
bei mir steht der Tod auch noch nicht
vor der Tür aber sucht sich schon mal im
Parkplatz ja
berühmte Leute zu zitieren so das ist
doch kein Spaß
älter zu werden und bei mir jetzt einer
sagen würde pass auf drehen wir noch mal
drei vier extra Schleifen durch sagen
oder nehme ich für immer 40 ja wunderbar
unter die unter den Voraussetzungen das
ist der körperlich halbwegs gut geht und
was ist der geistig halbwegs gut geht
aber wenn es ja nicht unmittelbar
garantiert und umgekehrt also mit der
Tatsache des Verfalls mit der Tatsache
dass irgendwann mal der Moment kommt
an dem vorbei ist haderst du mit der
Tatsache nein also ich ertrage
das Alter das ist ein Prozess den jeder
Mensch durchmachen muss und für mein
Alter darf ich nicht jammern aber ich
spüre eindeutig die
Reduzierung meiner Fähigkeiten so also
viele Fähigkeiten sind seit 20 Jahren
schon im abbauen und andere so und dann
Selbstbestimmtheit als wichtigster Wert
für dich in deinem Leben wie du genau
das was ich heute noch kann was ich
heute gern tue aber ich gehe weiterhin
positiv in die Zukunft und nicht negativ
ich habe Projekte für die nächsten Jahre
und ich werde wieder Projekte finden
dieses Büchlein dass er jetzt gemacht
haben an dieses Buch hat Jana erfunden
meine Frau sie legte mir eines schönen
Tages den Titel vor das Titelbild den
Untertitel und die Kapitel unserer sagst
du dazu sage ich das mache ich aber nur
wenn du auch mitmachst wenn du deinen
Teil schreibst und das ist eben da
versucht zu sagen das können wir mit dem
positiven genau und ich ich finde es
halt nur abschließend noch mal gesagt es
ist denke ich auch ganz positiv aus
diesem Gespräch heraus und mich nervt
umgekehrt das was da gerade die ganze
Zeit so ab als Apokalypse an die Wand
gemalt wird auch von wie ich finde
verantwortungslosen Politikern
PolitikerInnen die sagen da wird es
Unruhen geben da werden soziale Unruhen
ausbrechen die Leute werden übereinander
herfallen es wird alles ganz ganz
furchtbar Aufstände unser nein ich
glaube das alles nicht all das wird
nicht passieren da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher also wir müssen uns folgendes
klar machen
wir dürfen diese Geschichte nicht nur im
Hier und Jetzt erzählen und weniger in
die Zukunft schauen ausnahmsweise
sondern mehr in die Vergangenheit
wir haben die Industrialisierung
gekriegt kommt aus England und hatten
billigste Energie zu verfügen und in
einem guten jahrhundert eineinhalb
Jahrhunderten sind wir im Westen Reich
damit geworden aber nur weil wir
billigste Energie hat das war der
Schlüssel
und jetzt aus dieser Blase in der wir
leben
in die Zukunft zu schauen was die jungen
Leute tun die letzte Generation noch wie
sie sich nehmen Fridays for future und
so weiter
dass sie auf dieser Blase des Reichtums
heraus in die Vergangenheit schauen und
seinen die Verbrechen die die Welt
kaputt gemacht haben also wir und nicht
in die Zukunft und sagen wir haben jetzt
eine Verantwortung die haben das ja
ja und nicht willentlich getan sondern
sie haben diese billige Energie genommen
und haben eben diesen Reichtum aufgebaut
und dieser diese billige fossile Energie
hat uns die Möglichkeit gegeben das
Leben so zu führen wie wir es heute
haben und wenn wir das weitermachen
müssen wollen dann müssen wir korrektive
anbringen aber auch freiwillig weil wir
erkennen so billig kann die Energie
nicht mehr sein auch wenn sie
irgendjemand wieder billig verkauft
sollten wir sie nicht mehr so billig
halten wie sie war und wir müssen
natürlich herunter von den fossilen
Brennstoffen aber zuerst einmal muss ich
auch sagen dass wir nur hier sind
überhaupt diese Überlegungen zu haben
weil wir die billige Energie hatten aber
es hat noch kein Politiker gesagt dass
wir in den letzten 150 Jahren den großen
Vorteil hatten im fossile Brennstoffe
eben nicht weitergeht und an das
anschließend was du gerade gesagt hast
du hast gesagt wir wir werden das alles
nicht kriegen
ich halte es für wahrscheinlich dass wir
es nicht kriegen werden dabei viel
wichtiger für mich ist als eine
Prophezeiung zu machen ist zu sagen wir
dürfen in diesem Winter ja nicht die
massenhaften Proteste und so weiter
bekommen weil wir die Umstellung die wir
jetzt wegen Russland und wegen der
Ukraine machen ja ohnehin machen müssen
aus ökologischen Gründen das heißt wir
üben in diesem Winter Zukunft und das
können wir nur und da bin ich ganz bei
dir wenn unsere Politiker eine positive
Erzählung daraus machen und eine
positive Definition von Verzicht geben
und das nicht als quasi große Ausnahme
sehen in diesem Winter denn wir brauchen
jetzt eine ewige Folge große außen haben
wenn wir die ökologische Wände
hinbekommen so ist es genau und deswegen
für mich einfach als als Botschaft wir
können alle und das nehme ich aus diesem
Gespräch mit viel mehr als wir uns
gelegentlich so zutrauen richtig das ist
die Geschichte und das ist sich das was
man viel mehr auch den Leuten erzählen
müsste auch von politischer Seite und
die Stelle müssen
natürlich auch hoffen dass die EU
zusammen bleibt
in kleinen Kreisen funktioniert das
Zusammensein auch im prekären
Situationen gut sondern klaren Größe in
der nationengröße ist schon schwierig
weil die Empathie dann nicht mehr reicht
eine Weltregierung haben wir nicht
hingekriegt sonst hätten wir die großen
Probleme heute alle nicht aber die EU
kann nur gemeinsam diese Probleme nicht
lösen da passt die Weltbevölkerung aber
mindestens anstoßen die Veränderungen
anstoßen mit guten Beispiel vorangehen
aber wenn Sie die EU auflöst dann sehe
ich große Probleme also
bedanke mich ganz herzlich Reinhold
vielen Dank für die Zeit vielen Dank das
war war eine Premiere für uns das großen
Spaß gemacht vor allem euch beiden auch
ein bin mir auch beim Philosophieren
zuzuhören alles Gute dir und ein Wald
vielen Dank nächste Woche bis dann
[Musik]
Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas bei
OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]